ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show from the gas digital studio
in new york city
the original home
of the show that you are now watching
ben avery is with us the economy is
tanking i feel silly
that i spent 50
000
on the sunglasses that you're looking at
right now
50
000
i feel stupid about that there is a
diamond in the middle of them
50
000
these sunglasses once belonged to dodi
al-fayed
these were his sunglasses
r.i.p
all right
who was he for the retards audience that
don't know anything egyptian film
producer
and the son of billionaire muhammad
al-fayad how did he die he was the
romantic partner of diana princess of
wales when they both died in a car crash
in paris and the sunglasses were taken
off his head
they were sent to an auction house
and i have them now
that's what doing well means
it's what doing well means
and i don't apologize for it
but of course uh it's pride month we're
here
ben's queer
get used to it
lil nas x is angry that he was not
nominated for a bet award neither was
i
little nausea he's saying that it's
homophobic
that's what his contention is he's
saying that the bet awards is homophobic
and that it has prevented him
from uh
that has prevented him from being
nominated
um yeah zero nominations zero
nominations for little who in fairness
to bet
that is which is homophobic but in
fairness to them he is a horrible
musician
so you have a very strange
uh thing there where you have a horrible
musician he's a meme musician right he's
not good right the whole point is that
it's so bad it's kind of good it's like
a joke
and uh bet
that probably doesn't like
him
because he goes really hard with the
sexualized lyrics as he should be able
to do
uh as a gay guy he should be able to say
anything he wants
sell shoes with blood in them
you know whatever he does
what does he do doesn't he do like
really wild
yeah he does uh these things are
spectacles so he puts blood in a shoe
like in the doctor i mean with the with
the sex stuff isn't he like i'll eat
your ass yeah yeah he'll do music videos
too where like he's having sex with the
devil and stuff like that that's right
bobby did you have something that was a
drop
oh is that just a drop
if you have something play it no i was
just going through his videos now oh i
had the wrong audio that's all right
well we feel bad for him because i think
he should be able to [ __ ] the devil
and be rewarded what kind
of society do we live in
where
you can make millions of dollars
simulating sex with the devil
but are not rewarded for it
by
bet
do you want to live in that society do
you want to live in a society where your
only reward
for having sex with satan
is millions and millions and millions of
dollars in fame and not
a statue
given to you
by bet to confer
legitimacy
on whatever it is that you're doing
but
we feel bad for little nazaks
but we feel worse
for the people
i just remembered these sunglasses cost
70
000
i remember that now
these are 70
000 i had to pay for this
tell us about this economy because it is
one of the worst we've ever seen and
people are going to probably i mean
i don't even know
i can't even speculate how bad it's
going to get so the dow right now is sex
work
i mean
doug standup had that great bit
strengthen up your [ __ ] [ __ ]
go google that
but sex works not even gonna cut it
really in this econ like i don't know
what you're gonna be able to do
selling your children to a human
trafficker in the philippines ain't
gonna do it
robbing elderly people of medication and
reselling it on the dark web
ain't gonna do it
it's the type of economy where the most
horrible things that you can think about
the links that you would push yourself
the things that you could
never even imagine justifying but on
some level you know that if you had to
eating a person whatever it is whatever
your line is
going well over that line
just to survive the things that you know
that you might in some
horror hell world
endgame apocalypse
have to do won't
even
cut it in this economy it won't help
it won't help
the
allowances that you make
morally
to steal to cheat
to take advantage of others to
manipulate
to engage in outright acts of violence
intimidation betrayal against friends
against family
the lies that you will tell not only
yourself but those close to you
the things that you in the dark recesses
of your mind
know
that you could only do with your back
against the wall and a gun to your
mother's head will not suffice
in this economy they won't suffice
it's going to be a whole new game plan
because everything that you're prepared
to do
even things that you're not prepared to
do it's gonna get so bad out there that
you it's i mean i i can't even describe
how bad it will get in fact
i can't even begin to
fathom
every film
about things that are bad cannot even
get close
to what they predict is coming
breadlines will be
quaint cute you will wish you were on a
breadline when this hits and it's gonna
hit
and this is by the way every youtuber
in the financial space but when this
hits
you will wish you were on a bread line
you will pray to god
that you could just stand peacefully on
a line without the threat of murder to
get a nice loaf of warm bread it will
not happen
it will be a minute to minute scratch
that
second by second
test of your wits and your ability to
survive and the only thing
the only thing that might help you in
such a time is my newsletter
which you can
subscribe to and we email you once a
week
not annoying no pro just my newsletter
is the only thing that might help you
out where we give you all the up-to-date
information no but tell us how bad it's
gonna get because
bitcoin is now under 20 000 bitcoin the
thing that was here to save us
is now
under
dollars eighteen thousand nine hundred
eighteen thousand and you know what's
coming next the house
the house is coming
meaning
people you know
people think
people think
that they're safe with their money in a
[ __ ] house well that's coming next
the housing collapse but tell us
bitcoin is where eighteen thousand nine
hundred eighteen thousand dollars i'm
looking at the graph it hasn't been here
since december 11 2020. that's right
yeah
and then the dow is basically right
where it was at pre pandemic
so it's it collapsed it rose rose rose
rose rose and now it's back to where it
was in uh january of 2020 right before
everything with the show well there were
some ill-gotten games
and
you know
i don't know what to tell everybody
unfortunately
uh there's a big correction they are
driving the market
into
pull up what mike novogratz said here
about the economy and how they're going
to combat inflation they're going to
drive the economy into a recession it's
a minute 24 second clip
um and i should have sent it to you last
night but i like seeing you struggle i'm
saying it's bobby but this clip kind of
explains what's going on the rate hikes
to they're making you pay to borrow
money now
they're making you pay for it
and when the interest rates go up the
party goes down
and mike novogratz he's the ceo of
something or other you know these people
they're always the ceo of like you know
you know i don't know poseidon capital
whatever it is mike novogratz basically
says
jerome powell at the fed has decided to
push the economy into a recession to
combat
inflation which is probably the only way
to do it
that is what
that is what
people are now
kind of waking up to that there's not
going to be a soft landing they were
they were using the term soft landing
where like you get to keep your house
they've decided that's not possible you
cannot have a soft landing
what you will have now
is the hardest of landing
like hitting water
from thousands of feet a smack
to the concrete it will feel like you
fell off your bike in front of all of
your boys in sixth grade like i did and
you will get rocks in your elbows like i
did and permanent scars because your
parents don't care about you and they
don't take you to a plastic surgeon it
will feel like that
wind getting knocked out of you hitting
the concrete in front of everyone you
know
pain but also embarrassment
shock but also disgust
with a little bit of disgrace that is
what they've decided do we have the clip
up it's nine minutes of vamping do we
have the clip great
let's play this clip because i do
believe this man is entirely correct
soft landing is out
brutal
vicious
like 911 guy who jumps out of the towers
the way he landed that's the way this
economy is going to land i feel like an
idiot spending 80 000
on these sunglasses and you want the one
on a bloomberg right that is correct
yeah bloomberg technology i just emailed
it to you bobby it's uh we should do a
show
where it's just at the hour of getting
the clips
where we just cut from
getting the clip to the clip
because between him and bobby we could
do a show of this and we have a 60
minutes of the show of just finding the
clips because that's the real fun
thank you
about how this year could have been the
year for d phi it was actually the top
pick you had for this year
now
fast forward six months how do you feel
about that part of the industry at large
uh not great uh you know like
listen
you have to hold crypto in context
what's going on macro
right and we we talked about there were
going to be headwinds this year because
the fed was going to have to withdraw
liquidity and so assets that went up
based on cheap money forever if they're
this is not the club
but that's okay
the clip is
the economy is going to fail very
quickly mike novogratz
i can't wait till podcasting's over it's
going to be over in about six months
because all of these people are going to
live on the street including him right
next to me they are all going to live on
the street podcasting is quickly coming
to an end imagine the money they've made
you think i've made money i have talent
imagine the money that has been made by
podcast producers over the last few
years if you knew what these people made
you would be enraged
like chris rock had a great line he said
if americans knew how rich rich people
were they would never stop rioting if
you knew
how much podcast producers made you
would go to their houses and kill their
families but bobby thank you that was
the correct clip
six more months i need to ask you a
question that we're getting from a
customer actually a bloomberg terminal
customer who wants to know from you why
would you use a 200-day moving average
here after the fed funds uh
went up 25 basis points for three or
seven thirty days before the rate hiking
cycle started so how do you kind of
recalibrate here with
the 75 basis point hike how do you
recalibrate given that we're in a new
paradigm listen i think
what the fed said
really clearly was
and we've been talking about this for a
while when you have inflation as strong
as we've had you need to put the economy
in a recession to stop inflation and
what chairman powell said yesterday very
clearly is i will put the economy in a
recession to stop inflation even though
i have a dual mandate and i talked
cheeky about trying to get a soft
landing
guys who have done this for a long time
realize that soft landing is impossible
and so the economy is going to go into a
recession it's going to go into a
recession fast
you saw housing starts today they
collapsed
you're going to see the economy just
screeched to a halt
uh that's what the fed needs to do to
get inflation down
and so we're going to go through this
awkward period where growth is going to
be rolling over
and inflation's still going to stay
stubborn before it rolls
when the fed sees it rolling and they
signal the pause then you'll see crypto
take off you'll see other assets follow
okay so that
is what now do you understand ben what
he means there no i i don't understand
finance or the economy
ben see you're being wise you're trying
to be a while i really don't right
you're trying to be a wise guy
but the reality i understand what he
means
and
what he's saying right now is that
there's only one course of action that
we have and it's to take people like you
and your family and make them feel pain
to make them feel a lot of pain
that's what he means what he means
is that avert your eyes
because people like you and people that
grew up in places like you did are going
to have to feel pain now
not so much people like me
people that can pink their skin
on the tropical beaches
and be buttered
like soft rolls
with coppertone sunscreen not people
like us but people like you dirt people
people that go from town to town like
modern day gypsies trying to find bags
of wheat
you're going to have to feel it the pain
i mean and is it right i don't know
but it's happening
look we're all adults here and i know
some of us choose to use nicotine to
relax focus or unwind after a long day
lucy is a modern oral nicotine company
that makes nicotine gum lozages and
pouches for adults who are looking for
the best most responsible way to consume
their nicotine it's a new year why not
start out by switching to a new nicotine
product that you can feel good about i
i've not had a cigarette for 12 days
because of lucy i also had bronchitis
but it's lucy
if you enjoy using nicotine you should
definitely check out lucy's products at
lucy.co that's lucy.co
and use promo code tim checkout
warning this product contains nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical
remember if you're interested in a
better way to use nicotine visit lucy.co
and be sure to use the promo code t-i-m
yes
i would just like to add that i used
lucy and i uh stopped smoking as well
but i i actually did it it actually
worked so
lucy.co uh codetim
steve will do it as a good friend of the
show you know steve steve is a guy that
uh is a member of the nelq boys sketch
prank comedy group but he's much more
than that he's a gambler
uh he's a drinker
he is a national figure
he is someone who inspires people he
gives kids with cancer aetherium he
gives homeless people
uh uh
booze he helps he helps people
this is steve will do it is a guy
who will go
and and teach people how to gamble using
a crypto and a vpn he's a man
that says life is to be lived to the
fullest
even if it has to be
from a small private island
where there are no laws steve will do it
we'll do it he will do it
no matter what it is
yes is steve eventually going to die
in a high-profile automobile accident in
miami to be sure to be sure will he
crash
uh through the lobby of a hotel yes will
it be a helicopter accident sure will he
maybe die in a third world country where
he's living uh with a villa uh in
multiple wives sort of like uh
apocalypse now you know colonel kurt
style you know yes
um is uh the future of steve will do its
life uh sort of uh
terrifying yes but very interesting like
is he going first of all at this point
does a guy like that what can you even
what's left to do in america right right
right so correct so much like joe rogan
where joe rogan has gone to colonize
austin texas the crown jewel
steve will do what i believe will
eventually flee this country and
um establish some third world
fiefdom where he will lord over uh like
some uh type of savior convincing the
natives that he has powers ordained from
god
and it will be wild to watch it will be
amazing
think of every cult documentary you've
ever seen
um
plus
bitcoin
um and and and and we love see we'll do
it and we want to plug his uh youtube
channel
what right yeah it's right it's one
isn't that what we're doing it's one
word steve will do it and he also has a
second channel you can follow where he
uh gambles on there and it's fun and
what's fun about him is you know that
whatever he's going to have this
wildlife
and then whenever it ends it's going to
be so bad
and amazingly uh
phenomenally bad what he'll end up doing
like he may cause a war
it's going to be so
visceral and crazy to watch
um
but
it it
up until that moment it is going to be
incredibly entertaining it is going to
be so entertaining um
he gives ar-15s
to lonely
men out there that need them
he is the guy that america needs he's
the guy that america needs
he gave
the nalk meta card
to the
one uvalde cop who went in
the rest of them of course
were busy
you know what are you gonna do
housing is bad it's brutal vicious get
up the housing numbers housing starts
are down people are not applying for
mortgages
well over 40 percent of the
uh mortgage market like people in the
market for loans has collapsed
house uh building
has fallen to the lowest level in
decades
um
housing starts
people are not buying homes
people are terrified rates are up over
six percent they cannot afford
houses
so many of them
cannot afford houses
that the la uh the los angeles homeless
population
which is right now about 40 000 people
i imagine within two years will be
three four
million
people
and my attitude now about because rick
caruso lost the guy who was saying
i want to um
get rid of homelessness
people said no
no you don't
no you don't
his campaign was let's put homeless
people in affordable housing i'm not
going to say the other thing
satirically that i said last episode
which got me
age gated
explain very quickly what happened
with a crew so now with the last episode
oh yeah so since it's age gated uh
i tried to talk to youtube about this uh
the last episode i mean it's like
talking to a drunk have you ever spoke
to a drunk
so youtube declared that the last
episode is only available to someone
with a youtube account that is verified
they are 18 years or older now i tried
to appeal this the majority of our fans
are seven years old
that is who this show connects with the
children so i tried to appeal this they
knocked it down
then we talked to youtube we finally got
through
we said this is satire you don't
actually want to boil homeless people in
a pot it's a satirical
show they said we understand that it is
comedy and it is satire but it is still
satire that is not appropriate for
someone under the age of well then
nothing is well then nothing's
appropriate
so we lost we lost yeah
it's the time for you to get in the game
with me now
you need to get in the game right now
the [ __ ] is wet
spotify come to me
and give me money
and i will join you
come to me now
let's stop this
pussyfooting around
stop telling me you're not interested
stop refusing to give me money
stop saying we're going woke
the guy that made the rogan deal we
pushed him out of the company and we
hired some woman
who's trying to do a project with the
stars of friends no one gives a [ __ ]
what the stars of friends have to say
about
the [ __ ] the world okay stop making
celebrities do podcasts i'm sure jason
bateman is a swell guy
no one wants to know what he thinks
about anything he's a brilliant actor
and i love everything he does but that's
the only capacity that i want him i do
not care what his hot takes are i
i think this era of celebrities doing
podcasts will ruin it i am uninterested
in jennifer aniston's take on anything
who in god's name
wants to know
what courtney cox
has to say
about russia
shut it down
shut it down now
start with the nostalgia these shows
were big 30 [ __ ] years ago
i was nine years old
when these shows were big i'm 71 years
old right now
let it die
people
that are good at podcasting are good at
it precisely because there is no other
option for them
so they get good at it or they die
what motivation does jennifer aniston
have
to be really really
entertaining on the mic
what's the motivation for jason bateman
can someone share that with me
when jason bateman gets in his tesla or
jennifer aniston gets in her chariot and
they take her from whatever perch she's
at and they drive her
to a studio
where she has to go
and sit
in front of a microphone what is her
motivation
to make anything good
there isn't one it doesn't exist
none of these people can ever
share their real thoughts with you
because that's the deal the deal they
made which is a good deal was to shut
their mouth and every time they went to
open it oh here comes the money
money
keep your mouth shut and here's the
money
and now we go hey
how about just be you hey
you know how you've spent 30 years
becoming someone that isn't you
because you doesn't exist because you
wasn't interesting because you didn't
matter
because you was from a [ __ ] dust
ball town
suburb of illinois wherever these people
are from no one cares about you
they care about rachel and ross and
whatever the [ __ ] you wearing along came
polly and
they care about ozark and they care
about arrested development
they don't care about you
so shut up
and go back to work and leave our
[ __ ] thing alone you're not gonna be
good at it
what the [ __ ] are you gonna say
what is jennifer unless
unless
people like jennifer aniston
really lose their like unless they
really for whatever reason just
like like start like complaining about
their maid
like for the first 30 minutes of the
episode and go like i don't know where
she's from honduras or something but
i'll tell you right now i don't trust
her and i watch her i have to watch her
and i don't like that
if it goes in that direction it could be
great
like if jennifer aniston spends 30
minutes of the opening salvo of her show
complaining about her maid that's faking
long coven
like if jennifer anderson is like this
[ __ ] says she has long coveted she's a
liar
and she puts on like a wheeze
and her breathing she pretends to have
labored breathing and jennifer anderson
goes it disgusts me and i wish i could
call her out on it but i can't if that's
the direction it goes but you know
that's not
what is going to go they're going to
this is how they kill podcasting how do
they kill podcasting tim you're always
so dramatic i'll tell you how they do it
the plan the plan is to kill it the plan
is to kill it
what they're going to do
to kill podcasting is they're going to
let
vapid
celebrities do it
and they're going to market it and
advertise it
to the in the same way that they kill
everything else you're going to get so
sick
of the idea that that people that are
good and anti whatever you want to call
it are going to have to do something
else and i don't know what that other
thing is it might be twitch it might be
meeting people in the woods i don't know
where it goes but what it's gonna not be
is it's not gonna be
hanging out with jason bateman
jennifer aniston
whoever else they put out here again
who's i have a a lot of respect for
their work
get the [ __ ] out of a cheap studio with
i'm drinking on a plastic cup our life
is hell
why do you want this
what are you gonna you have millions and
millions of dollars
i gotta sit and wait for him to get a
clip up for nine minutes
can i be on friends
why do you want this life can you not
but they need to kill it
they need to kill it and how they kill
it
is by
flooding this space
with celebrities with nothing to say
not only do they have nothing to say
they are contractually
obligated to say nothing
by existing
their existence is the contract the
contract is they are unable to say
anything they will be handed talking
points at the beginning of every the
ukraine
is a powerful
i believe that the trans
the blacks are being killed like that's
all they're gonna do they're gonna be
handed a script every single day
and they're gonna read the script
i don't have a script i have ads of
companies that are not going to exist in
three months
because i'm a podcaster leave us alone
i have 90 000
sunglasses
because the mossad had to kill princess
diana because she couldn't mix royal
blood with arab blood google it look
into it are you going to talk about that
jen
is jennifer anderson going to talk about
the mossad hit against princess diana
for mixing royal and and muslim blood if
that is the case
i am wrong
egg on my face boy do i want to have egg
on my face is jason bateman he's so
goddamn quiet
is it his whole thing he's like quietly
intense
sure yeah
there's nothing left to do stop it you
all have enough money piglets
description
what are we gonna do if jack nicholson's
gonna have a podcast how bad does it get
we're gonna take every icon and legend
and we're gonna make them die podcasting
that's how sick this business is
but where was i before this housing
starts because i didn't i got lost there
housing
what's going on with the housing
what is happening so right now with
people's homes so right now mortgage
rates this is an article from june 16.
what's going on mortgage rates in the
u.s jumped by most in 35 years [ __ ]
weren't you and your wife gonna buy a
house we were thinking about well now
you don't yeah i don't know where well
now you're [ __ ] maybe not why not well
i'm gonna wait till we have a
conversation with someone later maybe
she'll tell me i'm she's not gonna tell
you [ __ ]
she's gonna tell you to go scratch wait
until she sees your income she's gonna
come in here and do your job
she's gonna go he gets paid what for
what
you know what jason bateman and jennifer
anderson gonna pay their producers
nothing
nothing
they will pay them nothing
it will be a terrified person
at [ __ ] whatever yeah ir radio that
comes in and goes
and they will run away and they'll press
a button because he'll be terrified of
course that's not the case here
i am constantly attacked and belittled
i i live in fear of these people i live
in fear of the system
not jennifer aniston
now
you were gonna buy a house but i'll tell
you right now you missed your window you
had a window and you missed it and i
told you to act and you didn't act you
told me on the phone a month ago you
said you might try to get something
before all the the but now it's over is
it over now you'll never own yeah for
the rest of your life you will rent you
will rent which is what blackrock wants
you to do rent
and you will [ __ ] lease and you will
rent and when your children say daddy
what do we own you'll say we own [ __ ] we
owe nothing we don't own [ __ ] the
socks you're wearing we owe nothing
we've leased it all you'll grab the food
out of his mouth and give it to his
sister and go you don't even own that
that's what's gonna happen
because you didn't heed my warning and
work harder
have you worked harder the show would
have made more money
this show makes and by the way because
of the economy so bad we are doing a
special deal on patreon right now five
dollars a month
if you want extra episodes of the show
five dollars a month 99 cents an episode
you can get into the show
but this is what i mean about the the
housing here it's a real problem uh it
climbed from 5.23 last week to 5.78 this
week the highest it's been since
november of 2008 during the housing
crisis people are priced out of the
market they're terrified they their
their retirement
accounts have been drained if they had
money in the market it's [ __ ] it's a
recession i mean
technically recession is two quarters of
negative growth but what you're seeing
right now is you're seeing a total
perfect storm of economic conditions if
you were thinking about buying a house
like people like you and your wife were
thinking about it but now you're seeing
everything happen
yeah cause i don't know if the house is
gonna be uh worth half in uh well also
you don't know
[Music]
how much that house costs you now versus
it might cost you a lot less
in a couple of years if rates can
stabilize and then fall
if we get out of this period
it might make a lot of sense to wait you
know right and and um
you know i mean i don't think you should
here's the deal
and i've told you this and i'll tell you
this
and i'm going to tell you this right now
a tent ain't bad
no i'm telling you this right now in a
safe area
a tent ain't bad yeah
you don't have kids yet
you and your wife
with a nice tent ain't bad
in a nice safe area
you have a gym membership you shower at
the gym
i'm telling you right now
the money you're wasting
living in a house that you rent
is money that you can spend
down the road get a tent
go to a a place where other homeless
people are
and set it up and join the community of
the unhoused i'm telling you right now
join the community because by the way i
don't even look at it as a negative
anymore people now people go oh la's got
all the homeless p yeah exactly
i think it's a pop i show people skid
row when you come to la i show you skid
row i go look at it here it is i go
we've got the most homeless people in
the world and then people are kind of
taken back and they're like oh that's
horrible you go why why is it horrible
are you so good because you own a house
throw it back on them
get into a fight with them
go what's so good about you that you own
a house
i'm proud of skid row
i'm proud that we have 40 000 homeless
people i want more i am proud that we
have the largest unhoused community in
america you will not shame me
you will not cause me
to re-evaluate
my love of the city of leicester it is
all perspective and i say [ __ ] it
good
make skid row a stop on the hollywood
tour that's all
done done
see it there it is
it is the and by the way
you can say it nicely it can feel nice
if you go
and uh to your left and to the right
you are seeing the largest
unhoused community in the united states
of america
and if you say it like that
people get the idea that it's actually
not a bad thing it's actually not a big
deal
and throw it back on the people that
judge it
go oh are you so good because you own a
house
who cares it's not a big deal
they're an unhoused community
some people houses some people don't
this is what we have to start accepting
i think we have to start accepting it i
do i don't believe that
i don't believe we should go nuts about
oh there's children that are living on
the streets you know what
you know
what children are on the streets anyway
they love
playing you know when i was young i
loved leaving my house and playing with
my friends on the street we're on the
street
i never wanted to come in
the saddest part of my day was what my
mother and father said come in here you
got to go to sleep
leave them out there
children enjoy being on the street and
they're resilient
they're resilient and they enjoy being
on the street it's not a big deal
it is
unzip the tent oh look who's playing
soccer not a big deal it's fun it's a
fun life
and i'm looking at it like that because
i i'm i'm sick of
how how people have
destroyed
and disgraced me
i'll tell you this folks
i love expressvpn
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like walking your dog in public
without securing them on a leash most of
the time you'll probably be fine but
what if one day your dog runs away and
gets dog napped
folks let's just go off to dome here the
point is this companies are trying to
take your money they're trying to steal
your information you know why they're
trying to do that
because it's profitable for them to do
it it's profitable for them to sell your
information
the government is trying to get your
information because they want to use it
potentially against you one day in a
court of law
um so how do you protect yourself you
use a vpn like expressvpn okay
get three months of expressvpn free and
expressvpn.com tim dillon
that's expressvpn.com tim dillon
expressvpn.com
tim dillon it works on all your devices
phone laptop tablet even on your smart
tv it's so easy to use just fire up the
app and click one button to get
protected it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so they can't get it they can't
hack it
and when you were in england you use
this on your phone when you're abroad
and i use this on my computer because i
wanted to watch ozark
it's true
now jason bateman's trying to take my
job
as a thank you
that's going to be the end of my life
i just i'm like this i just fiddled with
the michael yeah
keeps are you bald cut it out keeps
thank you anyway
now
stop being bald
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35. more than 50 million men in
the us suffer from male pattern baldness
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of his competitors there are only
two fda approved medications that can
prevent hair loss keeps offers both it
all for simple affordable stress-free
ways to keep your hair convenient
virtual doctor consultations 24 7 care
and support and what else does it have
low cost
is it cheap yeah treatment started just
ten dollars per month cheap
and it works yeah it offers a generic
version of two fda approved medications
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
it's cheap and it's good yeah they're
affordable it's cheap and it works
it's half the cost of pharmacy it's half
the cost how do they make any money
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keps.com
slash tim dillon or receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dylan to get your
first month free k-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dunn those are the ads
and uh
in terms of uh we have family members
that
use keeps i've yes yeah i i personally
do and it actually works i have a family
member that uses keeps right now why are
you shaking your head okay go on
i have a family member that uses keeps
right now
he's got a beautiful head of air
what's going on with the economy is it
still [ __ ]
i have 85 000 sunglasses on right now
as bad as the economy is doing right now
people are still uh they're well they
have jobs
the one indicator people have jobs
people can shovel [ __ ]
right now they have jobs they can clean
out the machine
and they can clean the hair
out of the frozen yogurt machine
that's one thing that we've got in this
country still we still got jobs you can
sweep the vomit off the floor
you can clean the fingernails out of the
crate maker
we still got jobs fear not
fear not
if there's hemoglobin on the waffle
throw it out make a new one there are
jobs
if there's pus
stuck
in the [ __ ] espresso machine
clean out the puss and then make the
americano there are jobs
of course the amount of money that
you're paid for those jobs hasn't really
gone up the problem with housing is
housing should have gone up with wage
growth but it hasn't
wage growth has gone up at the very high
end for a few people podcasters
uh human traffickers and people in tech
and but for most people it hasn't so
these housing prices are out of whack
now
you're gonna see them come down to
reality but thankfully there are still
jobs now go to help wanted new york city
go to help wanted and tell them what
they can do in fact go in austin texas
because new york's over help wanted
austin texas show them
what they can do if they want to get a
job
in austin texas
what if they are all jobs at joe rogan's
comedy club
that is not doesn't exist yet it's just
300 jobs okay i found one yes uh
delivery specialist
beautiful at a company called fetch
[ __ ] yeah tell them about it uh we're
not even getting paid to do this first
uh folks as a delivery partner you will
be responsible for picking up packages
from fetch facilities and delivering
them to apartment communities during
your chosen delivery time block see
what's good about this job is you can
choose when to do it and when to lay on
your couch and wish for death
that's what's nice about this job you
have the freedom to do it
but you also have the freedom to there's
a window you can do it and there's
another window when you can lay on your
floor and pray that you don't wake up
what is the compensation in fetch oh
let's see here so that is
let me click on that usually they say it
right next to it this one doesn't it
does not uh this one is 19 an hour
beautiful
too much
what else uh we have uh here we have a a
dishwasher
okay nothing wrong with that uh curry up
now
too much curry smell yeah 14 an hour not
great
you smell curry all day you'll smell
that curry it's [ __ ] up uh this one
says full-time floater in uh parentheses
caregiver
i like this one okay
so full-time position for experienced
caregivers cna this is a full-time
floater position consisting of providing
care to clients training caregivers and
assisting with office tasks as needed
let's see what they're paying that one's
probably pretty somewhat decent right
right
uh
you have to inquire okay well
it's not really the best ad
honey baked ham company production
associate
[ __ ] yeah
so this position let me tell you right
now
we have one of these in long island no
cigarettes 13 days
they have one of these honey me ham
companies in long island what's good
about this is they do the spiral ham
with honey they have the sides like
cinnamon apples mac and cheese
baked beans
mashed potatoes and all the things
go on uh so this position is actually
for the production of honey baked hams
and turkey breast uh training is
involved in all positions we hand glaze
each ham and turkey breast oh yeah [ __ ]
yeah with one of our one-of-a-kind
glazing techniques
a crew of 12 will glaze and wrap product
for retail sales we take pride in
sanitation and the ability to
effectively manage our time so here's
your responsibilities at honey baked ham
you have to uh prep duties such as
washing and chopping vegetables or
cutting meat yes you have to maintain a
clean and orderly kitchen
and you have to measure ingredients and
seasonings
ooh
listen folks the jobs are out there
the jobs are out there here's one from
austin caring for local podcast
billionaire you will serve as a
caretaker
to a local famous podcast billionaire
your tasks include reminding him that
certain things he sees online are not
real
also reminding him that he said he was
opening a comedy club
so you have to
causing many people to move there
who hate it
and do nothing now
so
i mean could these mics i mean
oh
no get get in your seat
got three minutes left he fixes it now
um
such an interesting uh life that we live
here and uh
so grateful to the people that make it
possible the fans the listeners the
companies
the uh
asians
for running everything
um i have a hundred thousand dollar
sunglasses on right now because i don't
live in fear
um
there's not much to do uh
at the end here really other than just
wish everyone well i mean the economy is
going to be
so incredibly vicious it is going to
kill you and everyone you know your
families will be on the street they will
be selling their [ __ ] [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and dicks they'll be doing
everything they can
there's nothing you'll be plagued by
famine
by disease
there will be chaos in the streets civil
unrest violence
authorities institutions will lose all
uh credibility very quickly authority
will fall
there will be ragtag group of militias
that will be guarding and distributing
resources there will be
regional fiefdoms run by psychopathic
charismatic cult leaders people are
going to feel vulnerable for the first
time in a very long time there is going
to be climate catastrophes and disasters
compounding a breakdown of the civil
order there is going to be probably a
freeze
or shutdown of local and federal
government services there will be
nowhere to run you're not going to be
able to utilize public transportation
planes trains your automobiles will be
set on fire by
bands of angry children looking for food
you're going to be scavenging
trying to make the most out of what
you've got you'll be eating out of
garbages
okay you'll be living in tents if you're
lucky you'll be walking 10 11 miles a
day from state to state
like a post-apocalyptic film
you will choose friends based on who you
perceive that you can trust at any given
time this is going to change you will
wake up in the middle of the night and
they will be rifling through the food
that you have decided it was going to
last you guys a week they're going to be
stealing water you're going to have to
execute some of them in front of your
own children you're going to have to
keep them in you have to enforce a
certain level of [ __ ] authority
you're going to have to make people
scared and you're going to have to
punish
execute
beat
it's going to be tough
you will not be able to access any
medical care during this time
you're going to be uh you're going to
have to get good at
minor surgeries performing them on
yourself
and your children and other members of
your group
you're going to have to perform stitches
stitching your skin together when a
feral rabid animal has taken your arm
and turned it into its chew toy
you may have rabies you may not
you're going to have to get pretty good
at securing medication and drugs and
administering them
with your group of people
you know whoever you're traveling around
this country this disaster prone war
zone with trying to acquire resources
you're going to have to be able to
administer all types of drugs
medications novocaine you're going to
have to do minor surgeries you're going
to have to get and store food you're
going to have to understand
refrigeration without a refrigerator
spicing food appropriately how long
things can stay you're going to be able
you're going to make your own jerky
you're going to try meat in the sun
you're going to have to learn to fish to
grow to live off the grid you're going
to have to become uh familiar with
agriculture
farming
storm patterns
irrigation water
you're gonna have to do all of that
and while you're doing that
you can listen to jennifer aniston
or jason bateman
so at least you'll still have
entertainment
during this period of darkness
it will be like the noah's ark flood not
everyone will survive
there will be small groups of people
that through their own ingenuity and uh
propensity for cruelty
will be able to get ahead of other
groups
and i don't know which group you'll be
in and i pray for you
but just know
that while you are out there
struggling you will be able to listen
to courtney cox
talk about fun things
that happened on the set
of friends a show that was on in the
1920s when actors could afford to live
in new york city and nobody had aids and
they met one black person
just know
that the american entertainment system
will never fail you
because even though you are going to be
out there
trying to figure out how to set up a
legitimate government once ours has
fallen
when you were trying to get some of the
loose nuclear weapons
that have already been stolen out of the
cheyenne mountain base and many of our
underground military bases
when you and your crew is trying to
acquire weaponry and food
you will be able
to listen
to jason bateman tell you how ozark got
made
because that's what this medium has
always been about
rich
celebrity millionaires
telling you
how cool [ __ ] happened
while you lay on your couch
and pray for death
and that's
the great tradition
of broadcasting
it has always been for rich people who
are bored
who did a cool thing once and want you
to know all about it
while you sit in traffic
and shove another french fry down your
throat
but these my friends are the good times
so enjoy them while you can it's gonna
get a hell of a lot worse
not for me
and not for anyone i know
joe rogan will protect us
he will take us up on a spaceship with
elon musk where we will do stand-up
comedy in a zero gravity environment for
no one
the rest of you i believe will inherit
earth and fight over resources
until you are exhausted or murdered by a
rival tribe i will be in the sky
with uh elon musk and joe rogan
until i kill myself which will be about
three hours into that experiment
when i decide that i would rather be
having be getting disemboweled by wild
dogs than be on that ship
timdylandcomedy.com there are no live
dates there's no tour [ __ ] off and go
away
a book's coming i haven't written
i haven't written the book but it's
coming you'll buy it
i hope to get it out before the [ __ ]
war but i don't think i will
but i'm trying
i can follow ben avery but who gives a
[ __ ] for what a picture of a duck what's
he adding to this
go to our patreon if you want extra
episodes or to support the show please
support our sponsors like dick pill and
cigarette uh you can't have a cigarette
so take this
have you lost your hair
hopefully soon we'll get legal services
you want to see your kid again
press two
but please support all of our sponsors
please
it's important for us that you
support the companies that support us
many of these companies
they're not going to see the other end
of this
you know
but that's okay
are you nervous about what's coming or
are you gonna face it head on
no i'm pretty nervous you should be yeah
you should be as nervous as any human
being out there
you should be nervous
because the podcast producers are going
to be the ones when we tell everybody
the money you've made
they're going to go to your houses with
pitchforks and they're gonna drag you
out and they're gonna rape you
they're gonna rape you to death
and they should
by the way i will
um be a guest on
addison or bateman's podcast
and completely like just be like hey it
was good great thank you so much
thank you so much for having me
it's kind of an honor to be here
so if that happens just [ __ ] you
because that's what this game is
and i don't need your [ __ ]
i will dance my ass right into that
studio tomorrow to sit down with those
legends
what do you think i want to be here with
you
good luck everyone
you're gonna die
and it's gonna be in vain